[Música]
crisis política en honduras el país
tiene dos juntas directivas del congreso
diferentes luego de que los 18 diputados
expulsados por la presidenta electa
xiomara castró eligieran a su propio
líder del parlamento tendremos reporte
desde tegucigalpa
protestas contra la vacunación del cómic
19 y la mascarilla en washington estas
medidas siguen dividiendo al país muchos
estados gobernados por republicanos no
imponen el uso de tapabocas y otros
gobiernos demócratas si lo exigen para
estar en interiores
burkina faso decreta toque de queda
nocturno luego de los disparos
registrados en varios cuarteles
militares durante la madrugada de este
domingo y que generó rumores sobre un
intento de golpe de estado el gobierno
negó que se tratara de una toma del
poder
buenas noches y bienvenidos de nuevo a
las noticias de france 24 mi nombre es
maría clara calle y comenzamos esta
emisión en honduras los diputados que
fueron expulsados por la presidenta
electa xiomara castró instalaron su
propia junta directiva y ratificaron a
jorge cálix como líder del congreso el
viernes la mandataria electa los aparto
de su partido por no respetar el pacto
para escoger a su nominado mientras
ellos hacían su cesión en el norte de
tegucigalpa de manera paralela en la
sede del legislativo otro grupo de
congresistas escogió al candidato de
castro para presidir el congreso desde
tegucigalpa nuestra corresponsal que ni
a torres con los detalles
honduras podría enfrentarse a una nueva
crisis política por el fraccionamiento
del parlamento por un lado se han
elegido dos juntas directivas paralelas
la integrada por los diputados
disidentes que obtuvo la mayoría de
votos gracias al apoyo de bancadas como
la del derrocado partido nacional y por
otro lado está la junta directiva que
acuerdo a la presidenta acción para
castró y que nació a raíz de un acuerdo
establecido antes de las elecciones en
las que prometió la presidencia del
congreso a un representante del partido
salvador de honduras la misma presidenta
ha convocado a sus simpatizantes que se
encuentran aquí en los bajos del
congreso nacional en apoyo absoluto a su
decisión la mayor preocupación es que
castró gobierne con un parlamento
fraccionado y no pueda llevar a cabo
todas aquellas políticas de estado que
propuso durante su campaña según ella en
beneficio del pueblo
la oposición venezolana criticó las
condiciones del consejo nacional
electoral para realizar el referendo
revocatorio contra el presidente nicolás
maduro el pasado viernes el cn anunció
que el próximo 26 de enero daría un
plazo de 12 horas para recolectar más de
4 millones de firmas contra el
mandatario los opositores calificaron
este proceso como una bufonada césar
pérez vivas promotor nacional del
movimiento por el revocatorio nos
explicó previamente las dificultades de
estos requisitos para el tema en
revocatorio la ciudadanía venezolana
está totalmente dispuesta y lista para
ir a firmar pero no me pueden venir
faltando 3 días a decir 1200 centros
para recaudar cuando inversora en 44 mil
mesas de votación
eso es como meter 100 litros de agua en
una botella de un litro es absolutamente
imposible que los ciudadanos logren en
12 horas
ejercer su derecho en tan pocos centros
de modo que esto es una bufonada es una
falta de respeto a la inteligencia y al
derecho de los ciudadanos y es una nueva
demostración de porque nicolás maduro
tiene temor a que el pueblo venezolano
se exprese de modo que nosotros estamos
reclamando que se cumplan con las normas
que están vigentes tanto a nivel
constitucional como a nivel
administrativo para garantizar el
derecho a revocar miles de personas
marcharme un washington eeuu para
oponerse a las mascarillas y a las
vacunas contra el kobe 19 en algunos de
los carteles que portaban decían que la
coerción no es elección y es que la
administración de joe biden intentó
poner como obligatoria la inoculación
para los empleados de las grandes
empresas aunque la corte suprema-
bloqueó esa política el 13 de enero aún
así muchas compañías piden portar
mascarillas escuchemos lo que dice uno
de los manifestantes
estamos en una guerra de información es
por eso que los necesitamos
tenemos que sacar esta información
crítica para salvar a la gente la gente
está muriendo nos están matando con la
censura y la propaganda están
manipulando las mentes de millones la
mayoría del sistema de salud a muchos de
mis compañeros médicos les han lavado el
cerebro por completo para que crean que
no existe un tratamiento nos dicen que
nos vacunemos sin cesar y nos animemos a
nosotros mismos a pesar de que es la
única estrategia ha fallado está
fallando y seguirá fallando debe
detenerse
pasamos a noticias de áfrica en burkina
faso se decretó un toque de queda
nocturno luego de que se reportaran
varios disparos en distintos cuarteles
del ejército el gobierno de negó que se
haya registrado un intento de toma
militar del poder con paulo lucumí
tienen los detalles
confusión en burkina faso los habitantes
de la capital uagadugú escucharon un
intenso tiroteo en una base militar en
la madrugada de este domingo y en las
ciudades de calle y guagua ya los
residentes también informaron que oyeron
disparos en los cuarteles el gobierno
aseguró que eran incidentes localizados
y limitados
lo niego rotundamente en primer lugar el
jefe de estado no ha sido detenido
ninguna institución del país ha sido
amenazada los intercambios de balas se
produjeron menos de dos semanas después
de que las autoridades informarán que
habían detenido a doce personas entre
ellas un alto oficial del ejército por
un presunto complot y tan sólo un día
después de que cientos de manifestantes
tomaran las calles para exigir la
renuncia del presidente por lo que
califican de ineficacia para detener los
ataques yihadistas en el país africano
este domingo el pueblo burkinés volvió a
alzar su voz esta vez en apoyo a los
militares
ya hemos visto suficiente no queremos el
llanto no queremos los huérfanos ya
hemos visto suficiente el presidente
debe irse apoyamos a los soldados deben
resistir burkina faso ha tenido poca
estabilidad desde que se independizó de
francia en 1960 y es uno de los países
más pobres del mundo según informes de
la ong world population review los
ataques de yihadistas en la región del
sahel en áfrica occidental han azotado
particularmente a burkina faso malí y
níger francia mantiene un despliegue de
5000 soldados para luchar contra los
grupos armados insurgentes pero la
violencia ha cobrado la vida de 2.000
personas y ha desplazado a más de 15
millones desde 2015 según la agencia de
noticias afp
el presidente de armenia armen sarkisián
presentó su renuncia diciendo que la
constitución del país no le otorga a los
poderes suficientes para influir en la
política sarkisián llegó al cargo en
2018 pero su papel es en gran parte
ceremonial el poder ejecutivo recae
principalmente sobre el primer ministro
niccoló para cillian después de un
referendo en 2015 armenia pasó de ser un
sistema semipresidencial a ser una
república parlamentaria por lo que los
poderes presidenciales se redujeron
significativamente
y este lunes guinea buscará su
clasificación a los cuartos de final de
la copa africana de naciones de fútbol
frente a la sorprendente cambia el
seleccionado tiene a varios jugadores
importantes como xavi keita y cuenta con
una preparación física de primer nivel
france24 accedió a una sesión de
fisioterapia del elenco guinea
el día de partido para guinea
a pocas horas del pitazo inicial los
jugadores pasan sus controles de última
hora un ritual bien aceitado preparado y
sincronizado a la perfección bruno la
cruz es el fisioterapeuta del combinado
guineano junto a su staff llevan varias
horas trabajando línea ha invertido
mucho en su departamento médico 160 mil
euros en equipos de última generación
para luminoterapia crioterapia
ultrasonidos y resonancias magnéticas
combinados con técnicas tradicionales de
masaje un lujo que algunos de los
mejores equipos de europa no pueden
permitirse
a veces incluso los clubes de la liga de
francia no tienen este equipo es
material de última generación que se
adapta a cualquier tipo de lesión
deportiva
dispositivo en este rubro guinea está a
la par de algunos de los clubes más
importantes del mundo lo comprueban abi
keita centrocampista del liverpool y
capitán del sil y nacional
esto realmente nos ayudó muchos
jugadores dijeron que esta vez las
condiciones son mejores ha aumentado el
número de oficios disponibles vienen a
nuestras habitaciones y nos preguntan si
necesitamos algo es importante para
nosotros que sean poco el tiempo que se
pasa en la sala de fisioterapia también
es una oportunidad para relajarse
aumentar el espíritu de equipo y aliviar
la presión de una competición
internacional de primer nivel pero es
además una necesidad profesional de los
jugadores en mi situación en este
momento realmente necesito este
tratamiento es muy importante para mí
recuperarme rápido vienen partidos muy
importantes codo a codo jugadores y
personal trabajan en conjunto para
garantizar que cuerpo y mente estén
listos para el encuentro un enfoque que
hasta ahora ha funcionado línea solo
tiene un jugador lesionado antes de su
cruce de octavos de final contra gambia
y así llegamos al final de las noticias
ustedes esperen más entradas 24
[Música]